sideline to sideline he was a thumper
and a leader he was a captain of the
University of Michigan team
he is Devin Bush how are you Devin good
how you doing I'm doing fine where are
you calling in from what's where are you
are you in Michigan right now for the
pro day yeah I'll be right now at my
place just you know taking this just
kickin it getting ready for the pro day
on Friday how does it how do you prepare
for a pro day Devin walk me through what
you've done yeah um you just kind of
just stand straight that's a big thing
staying asleep and you know you just got
off of vigorous training for the combine
and you know depending on when you're
pro day is luckily mine was so fast so
you know you just get ready to go out
there and do some more drills or do
anything that you feel like you need to
improve on and work at those things the
time you get into your putti
okay so is this gonna be like your last
couple of days on campus before you go
elsewhere and get ready or you sticking
around I'm sticking around I'm just
gonna base myself out of Ann Arbor and
uh you know just have that last-minute
college experience you know my guys at
us and I just soak it all up because
suing us you know I'll be somewhere else
tell me a favorite Harbaugh story Devon
give me your favorite mr. Jim Harbaugh
story that you got oh it was one time
before game the night before you know he
was preaching toughness mental toughness
and just uh you know he brought the
story about how he didn't have any money
and uh his friend his parents came and
picked him up and his friend on a car
and you know they they drive off you
know the parents give a suggestion you
know this goes where I scream no coach
Harbaugh is like you know anybody like
ice cream ever loves ice cream but I
didn't have any money so uh as soon as
they pulled up to the the ice cream
place you know everybody is you know
getting ice cream or an ice cream and
you know that's why you know that Jim do
you want ice cream you know he got you
feel have any monies like you know right
in there I had to be tough you know I
wanted ice cream so bad and I didn't
have the money I had to resist it you
know so he said you told him no I'm good
I'm on the ice cream you know our
students for wince ice creams for
kids and I'm good stuff enough to beat
the odds and stay strong and not take
the ice cream so you know he said he was
sitting there watching me start
screaming he's staring at the ice cream
trip and down the cone and you know he's
probably stuffed because you didn't get
in the know getting ice cream and the
point of that is what's your ice cream
Devin thing and he was preaching on how
mentally tough you are that day and you
know he's you want to relay the message
okay Devin Bush Michigan prospect and
consensus all-american 2018 here on the
Rich Eisen show where does that ice
cream speech relate to the speech you
heard in 2016 prior to the Central
Florida game when a specific member of
the Michigan alumni base came back and
spoke to your team Devin you know when
Brady walks into awesome you know it was
just like you know everybody watches
everyone watches missing and everybody I
came through here they were missing they
cut on this again they may follow
Michigan forever
mm-hmm so you not only plan for today
you plan for the guys in the past the
guys in the future
well Devin I do deserve this I don't
blame you for bringing up Brady's name
but I was the one who spoke the week
before Brady Devin to your team come on
that's right you came you came maybe we
were probably you on like the 20-yard
line
on on the closest to the grass it's also
my fault for being sandwiched between
Jeter and Charles Woodson and and Brady
timing everything in life oh my gosh
alright I walked right into that one hey
what happened at Michigan State this
year
Devon walk me through everything that
led to you stomping on on the Spartan
logo on the field what in the world
happened in East Lansing it was already
kind of a lot of tension there in uh you
know it just came in and they locked
arms across the whole field and you know
I'm out there warming up you know couple
other guys got there warming up we got a
headphones on not not really aware
what's going on but no soon enough we
find me we look back in you know there's
the whole business thing and they're
walking through the whole field with
their arms locked and uh you know it was
just like the matter of disrespect to
the 13 you know they things tried to
walk through our whole warmup you know
walk through the whole field and keep
their arms like they never made a way
for us to get to their little line or
whatever they do I mean that's kind of
what kicked everything off and then they
came they went to the far side of the
field broke down the huddle came back
and ran to I once again you know he's
pumping and talking so that's where that
hole is being came up so it was just
almost like a disrespectful thing and
that's how I took it
so uh you know I wasn't trying to go out
there and uh fight before the game
because that's you know I wouldn't be
able to play I probably did suspend it
over them so the next best thing in my
logo you did scratch it up there - spray
painted and everything and you know
we're watching right now you needn't be
held back and and all that
did you see was was the coach of
Michigan State was was Dantonio smiling
I've seen him like like a moment and
then after that kind of like Venice but
I did see a my setter
mm-hmm I don't want to relitigate this
well actually I do want to relitigate
this I do you know
I wouldn't mind wouldn't mind doing all
of that were you asked about this at the
combine that moment at all was that
brought up to you oh yeah I was probably
at probably four times and what do you
think they were trying to determine from
you if you were a hothead or something
like that what do you say like yeah
behind you cuz I mean we never seen
anything like that before
I guess they wanted just to figure out
what really happened in my eyes so you
just went through it did did we just
recreate the combine right there or what
did you tell okay who did you speak to
with the combine walk me through that
[Music]
people I probably ate I can't like grip
and mothers have my hair but I probably
want to say I'm old I know most of my
probably were like four or five teams
okay
maybe do you wanna give me names drop
names it's okay I didn't meet with I'm
trying to think I didn't meet with uh
Cowboys
I didn't leave weight into the these are
teams you did not meet with yeah these
are team I didn't II was so all the
other teams I've met with okay so I'm
really good me with a whole bunch of
teams yeah well maybe you to meet with
Tennessee kiss rebels in Ohio State guy
Devon maybe that's what that is
so what's the strangest question you got
asked to the combine yeah and uh there's
like oh here's a kid I suppose
psychologist was that you request all
right so guys I guess look at me the
whole time my god
then he knows exactly questions just
simple questions there he goes having
like the fifth question he's like so how
long can you hold your eyes open like my
dog again like I don't know I never
really
calm myself doing that so he's like oh
looks like you kinda don't want to do it
right I I never show that but I he's
like my child like it so he brought out
his phone he's like you ready I'm like
ready
so he's already said go so I'll keep my
eyes open the whole time I'm thinking
I'm like why am i holding my eyes open
in a football baby I reposed to be
looking at football ready over here
staring at me keeping my eyes open so
I'm like all right so I just kind of
like let it go out and go out not blink
and then I my god like dang I tried in
his eyes oh that wasn't so good I'm like
oh how long was he sighs I was like nine
seconds I'm like all right he's like
well you want to try again I'm like no I
don't like he's like okay why not like
my eyes are Brandon I'm look I can go
any longer than that he was like okay
like room something down this little boy
oh my god so you had a staring contest -
we heard about that somebody who also
had a staring contest they said Seattle
did that was this Seattle that did this
with you huh okay we'll see we'll see if
if we're you know Seattle's on the clock
you know if she's on the clock they'll
take you we'll see how that goes if they
do their 21st overall but all the mock
drafts I see or your top 20 what are you
hearing talk to when you top the team
top ten late first round when they offer
like the free agency you know stuff to
happen these past couple of days you
know I like the Jazz is gonna be super
interesting and I think it's gonna be
about it you know a lot of a lot of like
turns and a lot of questions but I think
I'm ready to see how the jabs are gonna
play out because I think it's gonna be
an instant year this year with being a
lot of decent player - yeah I agree
last one for you your dad won the Super
Bowl
for the Rams Super Bowl 34
with a lot of good friends of mine
Warner and and Marshall Faulk have you
met any the greatest show on turf errs
through your dad or in contact with him
how did he came to contact with the
encoding stories about him expand with
them like the guys I do like the guys I
do know
I you know facing you know speak song a
lot on the people on the flesh speak the
rear doors and I speak everybody's
asking my father what are you talk to
Ray Lewis about I mean he is he must
really download you with a lot of stuff
looked like you were during the Ray
Lewis dance on the Michigan State logo
I'll be very honest with you Devon but
Ray that must that must be cool cream I
saw through them they're just baby so
you got down and seen your license you
know any questions or concerns I got or
I just want to have a nice little
conversation you know they they talk
about women okay Devon look this has
been a blast chat with you good luck to
you say hi to everybody there in Ann
Arbor
I appreciate you eventually remembering
my speech to the team a couple years ago
okay it's on YouTube
if you haven't seen it so check it out
yes take care of Devon go blue you
better that's Devon Bush calling in from
Ann Arbor before I er to his pro day
right here in the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience